le smic européen
c'est un sujet qui revient régulièrement
à bruxelles ces dernières années rien
d'étonnant puisque chaque pays de
l'union européenne à son propre salaire
minimum au sein même de l'ue eux les
disparités sont énormes
si vous êtes un travailleur bulgare
votre smic s'élèvera à un peu plus de
300 euros alors que si vous êtes
luxembourgeois il se rapproche de 2150
euros
cette fois plus élevés et chez six pays
membres l'autriche chypre le danemark la
finlande l'italie et la suède
il n'y a carrément pas de salaire
minimum pas étonnant donc que les
entreprises se délocalisent au sein même
de l'union dans ces pays sans smic ou au
smic très bas cela leur permet ainsi
d'économiser très largement sur la main
d'oeuvre tout en vendant leurs
marchandises partout sur le territoire
européen e dossier d'un fils qu'européen
est revenu sur la table lors du sommet
social de porto début mai et évidemment
les vingt-sept se sont mis d'accord et
l'ont adopté en fait non pas du tout le
projet est toujours dans l'impasse
forcément c'est complètement impensable
d'uniformiser les salaires deux pays qui
ont autant de disparités y compris sur
le coût de la vie et pour lesquels
parfois pratiqué dumping social ou
salariales faire venir les entreprises
des pays étrangers chez eux est
primordial pour leur économie
il ya aussi la question des traités qui
rendent l'opération compliqué pour
l'union du moins si elle ne veut pas
manquer de respect à la souveraineté de
ces pays
pas évident donc de s'attaquer aux
salaires le smic européen c'est vraiment
pas pour demain